mai 1968 le Festival de Cannes n'échappe
donc pas à la fièvre contestataire qui
gagne la France et finit après moult
débat par s'interrompre brusquement
voilà ce que vient de nous rappeler ce
documentaire réalisé par géomuibon mais
au-delà de cet épisode et au regard de
son histoire de ses programmations de
ses palmarès quels ont été les moments
où la politique c'est invité à ce
rendez-vous incontournable du monde du
cinéma nous allons nous poser la
question maintenant avec nos invités
présents sur ce plateau de débat doc
avec vous pour commencer Antoine de
Bègue bienvenue vous êtes historien
professeur d'histoire du cinéma à
l'École normale supérieure mais aussi
critique de cinéma et de théâtre votre
dernier livre Godard biographie
définitive est une réédition complétée
et définitive publiée c'est grâce à
merci d'avoir répondu présent à notre
invitation Guillemette audicino est
également avec nous bienvenue et vous
êtes journaliste chef de rubrique cinéma
à Télérama et chroniqueuse chez nos
confrères de France Inter et puis vous
êtes aussi membre du comité du sélection
de du Festival de Cannes et ce depuis
2020-2020 c'était une année où ce comité
de sélection contenait plus de femmes
que d'hommes c'était la première fois
dans l'histoire du Festival de Cannes
paraît-il oui parce que de l'année 2020
tout le une grande partie des festivals
du monde avait signé une charte pour que
il y parité dans beaucoup de domaines
dans les festivals et particulièrement
dans les comités de sélection
c'est-à-dire que les films choisis soit
choisis équitablement par des hommes et
des femmes pour après aller à les
concourir dans les pour les palmarès
mixité du côté du comité de sélection
pas forcément du côté des réalisateurs
et réalisatrices qui présente leur film
dans la compétition officielle il y
avait que trois réalisatrices femmes
l'an dernier sélectionné dans la
sélection officielle on en dira
peut-être un mot tout à l'heure beaucoup
plus cette année beaucoup plus cette
nouvelle Christophe carrière est enfin
avec nous
et vous êtes également journaliste grand
reporter à Paris Match spécialiste et
passionné s'il en est de cinéma vous
êtes entre autres l'auteur de Patrick
dewaerle l'écorché ouvrage publié chez
Michel Lafon il a jamais été primé à
Cannes Patrick dewaers la seule année où
il aurait ou il aurait vraiment pu
l'être et mérité de l'être c'était pour
serrer noir d'Alain Cornot et voilà ni
primé à Cannes ni césariser rien du tout
voilà non et série noire n'a rien eu
d'ailleurs quand on voit le chef-d'œuvre
aujourd'hui que c'est rétrospectivement
c'est un raté c'est un raté plusieurs
des ratés une fois n'est pas coutume on
va commencer l'émission en voyant un
extrait très court
c'est
Macha Méril qui nous parle de Godard en
68 bien sûr à ce fameux Festival de
Cannes
il y avait un leader qui était Jean-Luc
c'est Jean-Luc qui qui a trouve qui a
pris très vite la parole et qui a eu
toujours les mots les plus alors lui il
était très Moïse alors évidemment on
n'était pas toujours d'accord avec le
vocabulaire
tu es libre
Godard leader dans cette
dans ce fameux Festival de Cannes de 68
escaud delà de ça on peut dire que c'est
la Nouvelle Vague française qui a pris
le pouvoir et qui a pris le pouvoir ce
fameux mai 68 pour annuler et suspendre
ce festival de Cannes oui on peut dire
ça cette génération en tout cas et je
pense que c'est pour le comprendre il
faut comme le fait le documentaire
d'ailleurs qui de ce côté là il est très
intéressant il remet l'arrêt je dirais
la prise du Palais des Festivals de
Cannes dans une séquence qui est une
séquence très politique en 68 qui part
avec l'affaire Langlois quand Malraux et
et le pouvoir gaulisme renvoyer l'envoi
de la Cinémathèque jusqu'à jusqu'aux
effets de 68 c'est à dire les États
généraux du cinéma qui se tiennent à la
suite de Mai 68 donc c'est vraiment une
séquence politique où les leaders les
meneurs sont effectivement voilà le
l'espèce de quarteronde de de jeunes
déjà de généraux issus de la de la
Nouvelle Vague c'est c'est Godard mais
on le voit aussi sur les documents de
d'époque ces Truffaut ce qui est
beaucoup plus étonnant un Truffaut qui
est vraiment pas quelqu'un qui sait
engagé politiquement et qu'il a
monté ce fameux collectif pour la
défense de cinéma c'est ça en fait qui
ce qui a fait le ciment c'est c'est
l'angois et le ciment est là
l'explosion et l'explosion on peut dire
la suite de cette mobilisation qui s'est
fait autour de la défense d'Henri
Langlois comme symbole du cinéma c'est
c'est le Festival de Cannes oui qui qui
vient faut dire que c'était il y avait
quelque chose qui aurait été un peu
ridicule de continuer le festival alors
que tout s'arrête la France s'arrête et
en grève générale il y a 10 millions de
de grévistes pourquoi le Festival de
Cannes devrait continuer c'est c'est ça
la logique qui a qui a permis à ces
ce qui à ceux qui mènent l'assaut contre
la citadelle canoise de l'emporter en
fait alors il y a tout de même ceux qui
voulaient voir projeter leur film ils
sont là pour ça et puis on a vu tous ces
débats avec
un certain temps de réalisateurs
commencés par paulanski parce que c'est
un enjeu c'est un enjeu très fort le
Festival de Cannes surtout enfin pour un
jeune cinéaste qui peut exploser
littéralement en un film à cet endroit
là donc de jeunes metteur en scène comme
comme Polanski qui qui propose qui ne
sont pas encore arrivés au Pinnacle etc
on défile à montrer pour eux c'est c'est
une frustration donc évidemment il y a
un peu conflit entre différents
cinéastes mais ce qui est intéressant
c'est que finalement tout le monde se
retrouve quand même dans parmi ces
cinéastes pour ce qu'on va appeler après
la politique des auteurs etc c'est très
intéressant la politique des auteurs ça
veut dire qu'en gros ces cinéastes là
veulent reprendre le pouvoir sur les
institutions du cinéma ils l'ont fait
face à Malraux en disant attends c'est
pas toi ministre de la Culture qui va
décider ce que l'on gloire ou non à la
Cinémathèque est-ce qu'on va faire du
patrimoine du cinéma et là c'est pareil
ils arrivent au festival c'est pas une
organisation et des paillettes qui vont
décider ce que nous on veut faire avec
nos films et de la manière dont on veut
politiser notre cinéma donc en fait ils
reprennent le pouvoir ils prennent un
pouvoir politique sur leur propre
œuvres
il y a eu un après
et en avant 68 au Festival de Cannes
on va pas revenir sur 39 39 voilà
39 le festival n'a pas lieu pasteur
justement alors qu'il avait été fait
pour contrer venir la Mostra c'est ça
etc
voilà en 1937
à monsieur qui s'appelle Philippe
herlanger qui en fait les le créateur du
Festival de Cannes va à la mostrade
Venise et s'aperçoit que la Mostra de
Venise et noyauté c'est vraiment même un
euphémisme par le fascisme c'était alors
mussolinier là Hitler vient en visite
gobels est ravi enfin et surtout Venise
prime
un film de Lenny refenstahl c'est à dire
les dieux du stade qui a été commandé
par Hitler et le deuxième prix va au
frère un Cinéas qui est le frère de
Michelin
et donc ce Philippe herlanger qui en
fait le patron de l'association
artistique française en revenant de
Venise dans le train il bouillonne il
dit c'est pas possible le pour le moment
le seul festival de cinéma important au
monde est en train d'être complètement
face ça devient les nazis et les
fascistes qui qui s'amusent ensemble
éducation nationale police l'homme
politique qui crée le festival puisque
c'est à la décision de Jean Zay que
j'ose ai dit à ses équipes dont Philippe
herlanger on y va on propose un
contrefestival qui sera donc Cannes et
c'est vraiment une politique anti
d'ailleurs s'intituler le festival des
nations libres
c'est d'autant plus politique que il
faut le savoir c'est que c'est le c'est
le gouvernement qui envoie les films il
y a pas de comité de sélection le comité
de sélection ça va le démarrer à partir
de 1972 avant c'est chaque pays en voie
le film qu'il a envie ce qui va créer
d'ailleurs des des des soucis
diplomates diplomatiques notamment en
1956 quand les Allemands de l'Ouest ne
veulent pas venir parce qu'à l'époque il
y avait les deux Allemagnes les
Allemands de l'Ouest ne veulent pas
venir parce que ils programment en
compétition Nuit et Brouillard ils en
veulent pas dans la Rennais y aller les
voilà les Polonais ne veulent pas venir
parce que il y a un film je sais plus
lequel qui leur plaît pas donc il faut
retirer le film les Anglais il y a ils
retirent un film de la compétition parce
que ça va pas plaire aux Japonais ce qui
fait qu'au bout du compte c'est c'est du
grand n'importe quoi cette année-là et
la Palme d'Or je vous le donne en mille
c'est quand même très symbolique le
titre c'est le monde du silence de
Cousteau quand même magnifique donc
voilà à partir de 72 mais je crois que
68 ça quand même largement
et en 72 ils vont ils vont se décider
enfin à ce que bah je tiens un comité de
sélection que ce soit plus les
gouvernements qui décident parce que là
effectivement c'était politique jusqu'au
bout des ongles en fait c'est drôle
parce que c'est un événement politique
et une prise de pouvoir politique des
cinéaste qui va faire que le festival va
d'une certaine manière se dépolitiser
c'est-à-dire en tout cas ce dépolitiser
dans le côté diplomatique et un peu
effectivement arthritique du sens
c'est-à-dire ce seront maintenant les
créateurs qui seront au pouvoir et pas
les ambassades oui c'est c'est vraiment
une une véritable mutation du Festival
de Cannes et cette prise de pouvoir
politique des réalisateurs elle a aussi
un enjeu très concret à Cannes avec la
création de la Quinzaine des
Réalisateurs c'est un effet direct de 68
et du et du Cannes 68 les réalisateurs à
partir de ce moment-là mobiliser crée la
société des réalisateurs de films qui
dont l'émanation directe et la la scène
des réalisateurs donc à partir de 69 il
y a une sorte de contre manifestation
qui est ouvertement à la fois
cinématographique sont des auteurs mais
aussi ouvertement politique et la
sélection officielle elle est obligée de
réagir à ça si elle reste dans son coin
avec des films qui sont qui sont choisis
par les gouvernements par de façon
diplomatique mais elle sera ridicule
face à une sélection comme la quinzaine
donc elle voilà elle va très vite en
fait dès 72 effectivement
s'ajuster sur je dirais une nouvelle
donne du cinéma qui qui oui qui qui naît
de la crise de 68 donc c'est ça qui est
intéressant c'est que la crise de 68
c'est pas simplement l'arrêt du festival
voilà c'est pas et c'est vrai que à
l'époque il y avait une grande peur
est-ce que le festival va reprendre bah
en fait oui il reprend et puis il
reprend d'une certaine manière dans sur
d'autres bases et qui sont sûrement les
bases disons un peu d'aujourd'hui les
moderne du festival elle se crée à la
suite de la crise et ces bases modernes
vous l'avez vous l'avez dit c'est 1972
j'ai noté quelques palmes d'or d'après
72 80 l'homme de fer évidemment vacheda
95 underground customica alors
évidemment elle a fait polémique cette
palme d'or parce que lui on supposait
quand même qu'il avait quelques amitiés
avec le Bodin de miloz et vite l'ancien
président serbe qui depuis a été jugé
par la Cour pénale internationale 2004
Fahrenheit 91 évidemment de Michael
Moore alors là c'est vraiment
anti-bouche junior ce film et puis même
2022 sans filtre il est récompensé c'est
un film de de Ruben
otland
qui qui présidera effectivement le
Festival de Cannes cette année et alors
là on est on avait ça tient
particulièrement acide de ce qu'on peut
appeler les
Ultra riches bon ça quel sens c'est pas
le mode dehors elles sont vraiment
politiques celles que je viens de citer
elle sort donc lorsqu'on dit bah oui
Cannes s'invite à la politique quand
comment c'est pas le mot d'or c'est un
signe c'est un symbole vous vous avez
raison de citer celle-ci mais par
exemple Ken Loach qui a eu plusieurs
palmes d'or Ken LOA c'est vraiment
l'incarnation que ce cinéaste du cinéma
du cinéma politique aussi alors mais
c'est un cinéma disons plus largement
politique parce que il raconte et il ne
cessera de raconter jusqu'à sa mort la
pauvreté la lutte sociale le
néolibéralisme qui dévore les individus
donc de toute façon c'est vrai que
l'homme de fer en 81 là il y a vraiment
un symbole exactement mais mais c'est
vrai que de donner des Palmes d'or à un
moment à un film qui représente vraiment
un mouvement politique un débat
politique saillant une année ou une
autre c'est important et on peut
constater qu'à chaque fois ce sont en
plus de très bons films
la plupart du temps quand tu as un film
est palmé c'est parce qu'il arrive à
faire ce mariage assez magique d'un
engagement et aussi en fait d'une
efficacité émotionnelle quand il y a les
deux qui sont au rendez-vous ce sont des
palmes évidentes ce sont des palmes en
plus qui c'est important de mettre cette
palme sur une affiche je pense qu'un
jury peut y penser mettre une panne sur
une affiche d'un film qui dit quelque
chose de fort du monde dans lequel on
est pour que les gens aillent le voir
c'est important même le jury fait un
acte politique à ce moment-là Christophe
carrière dans les palmes d'or mais aussi
peut-être dans les palmarès des
Festivals de Cannes il y en a qui vous
ont dans la sélection tout simplement il
faut il faut se rendre compte qu'en fait
une bonne sélection de Cannes c'est une
sélection qui reflète le monde dans
lequel vous vivez chaque année c'est la
même histoire donc en fait ça évolue il
y a des années où on va plus parler des
femmes battues il y a une année on va
parler plus des enfants battus ça va
être il va y avoir des variables selon
l'année mais c'est ça se regroupe il y a
une vraie Co hérence on se rend pas
compte de la du boulot des comités de
sélection semblables parce que c'est
quand même
c'est comme déjà on sait la difficulté
pour composer une équipe de foot et là
si vous voulez c'est pas on joueur là ça
va être 75 films vous vous sélectionnez
75 joueurs sur une multitude et puis
alors comme vous le savez tout le monde
a son avis donc parce que comme des
êtres tout le monde a deux métiers le
sien il critique de cinéma donc du coup
quand ils vont voir les films on dit oh
non c'était mieux l'année dernière moi
ça fait j'y vais depuis 87 chaque année
je m'entends dire il y a toujours
quelqu'un qui vient de me dire c'était
mieux l'année dernière non tu dis mais à
force on va descendre jusqu'où comme ça
donc voilà en fait la sélection
ressemble au monde dans lequel vous
vivez donc forcément les politiques elle
a toujours été politique comme décide
n'est pas là tout est politique à partir
du moment où il y a un homme et une
femme se dit je t'aime ça devient
politique donc en fait le les palmes
d'or quelle qu'elle soit effectivement
ont du sens alors on aime on n'aime pas
mais elles ont du sens forcément
du même avis moi je suis tout à fait
alors je partage cet avis d'autant plus
que bon moi je vais au festival depuis
84 alors
cette excitation qu'on a tous
journalistes historiens voilà à aller à
Cannes c'est ça ça le reflète ça on va
avoir en une dizaine de jours
une sorte d'état du monde et plus cet
état du monde est précis et plus il est
je dirais conflictuel et plus il est
voilà plus plus tout d'un coup la carte
du monde clignote par les films de
Cannes plus on est excité on est on est
intéressé on va pas à Cannes pour faire
la fête on va pas à Cannes pour voilà on
va à Cannes pour voir je dirais les les
les 20 30 films qui vont compter dans
l'année ça c'est sûr mais on va aussi à
Cannes pour participer de l'état du
monde et pour voir alors moi j'ai des
souvenirs c'est vrai qu'en 91 92 on a vu
arriver des des films de la ce qu'on
appelait la pérestroika de l'Est qui
était voilà
d'un coup on sent à Cannes quelque chose
qui est de l'ordre d'une forme de
géopolitique qui se dessine bon l'année
dernière évidemment le discours des
Hélène ski comme ça en direct sur le
grand écran de la salle avec les
sélectionné c'est quelque chose qui
était très très fort et qui et donc
c'est canne c'est c'est ça qui je pense
et peut-être le plus fidèle à l'esprit
du Festival de Cannes tel qu'il a été
fondé c'est en fait d'être un un petit
État du monde en une dizaine de jours
alors là vous évoquez ce fameux discours
en direct en vidéo et à la cérémonie
d'ouverture de Cannes du président
zzzleanski c'était l'année dernière il a
toute sa place ce discours de Zelinski à
l'ouverture d'un festival comme Cannes
il y a pas le moindre doute là-dessus où
est-ce qu'on mélange pas un peu trop
pour le coup politique et et cinéma non
non parce que
fait le cinéma le cinéma raconte la
politique nous raconte effectivement
l'état du monde nous raconte les guerres
souvent ils nous les racontent une fois
qu'elles sont faites
là il y a quelqu'un qui est en guerre et
qui vient dire au monde du cinéma mais
aussi au monde de tous ces gens qui
filment et de tous ces gens qui
regardent des images voilà ce que j'ai à
vous dire et c'est important que vous
artiste ou caméraman ou spectateurs ou
public vous vous soyez avec nous je
viens vous dire d'être avec moi non
c'est forcément c'est le bon endroit
pour pour y être et puis en plus ce qui
est fou c'est que je crois que on le dit
dans le documentaire c'est que Cannes
est censé être une bulle alors en même
temps on y va pour prendre tout à fait
d'accord des nouvelles du monde
c'est-à-dire espèce de précipiter de la
géopolitique du monde et en même temps
on est comme dans une bulle et on aurait
tendance à pas savoir ce qui se passe à
l'extérieur c'est à dire on est en train
de regarder par exemple ce qui se passe
dans un pays africain grâce à un film et
on se rend compte deux jours après que
il y a eu l'affaire par exemple je
trouve ça je trouve Stan qui se passe à
Paris ou à New York et nous on est là à
15 ans oh le scandale Strauss-Kahn
machin bon donc souvent on est un peu
coupé du monde mais donc quand Zelinski
arrive il nous reprend aussi par le
parle pas le temps et tu viens prendre
des nouvelles du monde moi je viens de
je viens t'en donner des nouvelles et
des nouvelles très fraîches voilà donc
c'est ça qui est beau c'est cette cet
échange on est moins dans une bulle
maintenant parce que il y a les réseaux
sociaux donc je me souviens très bien
que à l'époque de l'affaire Strauss-Kahn
on l'avait appris à 2h du matin c'était
c'était la panique sur la Croisette donc
voilà mais c'est vrai que mais c'est
vrai que à l'époque de je crois que Kurt
Cobain s'est suicidé pendant le Festival
de Cannes et je sais que ça on l'a
appris
si on lisait pas les journaux il y a pas
les réseaux il y avait pas tout ça et
c'est vrai qu'on l'a appris après donc
effectivement on est dans un monde à
part il y en avait un qui avait donné le
ton il présidait le jury du Festival de
Cannes l'an dernier c'était Vincent
Lindon juste un petit extrait de son
discours mais il a eu frappé tout le
monde et le caractère politique du
discours de l'indon et frapper tout le
monde pouvons-nous faire autre chose
qu'utiliser le cinéma cette arme
d'émotion massive pour réveiller les
consciences et bousculer les
indifférences je ne l'imagine pas
est-il Vincent Lindon il a été peut-être
comme d'autres présidents de
Vincent
très politique mais quand Vincent la loi
du marché pour lequel il est le prix
d'interprétation masculine c'est un
c'est un acte militant carrément puisque
en plus il est payé au tarif syndical
pour faire le film donc il prend même
pas te cacher et il le fait parce qu'il
veut que le film me dise parce que ça
parle de la précarité ça parle d'un
chômeur longue durée perte d'un enfant
handicapé en plus et
comme quoi toute bonne action est
toujours récompensée puisqu'il a eu le
prix d'interprétation et je crois que il
a jamais gagné autant d'argent avec ce
film donc voilà donc mais ça part
vraiment d'un acte militant et ce film
était présenté à Cannes Antoine debeck
qui a tout de même des présidents de
jury qui sont peut-être plus politiques
que d'autres non vous allez peut-être en
tête là je pense que le président qui a
marqué l'histoire de Cannes et ses
Rossellini en 77 c'est peut-être le
premier voilà grand grand cinéaste et
puis Rosellini en 77 quelques semaines
avant sa mort c'est peut-être la
dernière acte qui fait de présider le
Festival de Cannes c'est vraiment un
président très politique et qui va
mettre en avant un peu contre son jury
c'est voilà le côté très peu autoritaire
et je dirais un peu magistral de
Rossellini il met en avant pas de repas
de Rome des Tavi Yannick et un film
voilà que pour la télévision qui n'est
pas du tout et et c'est un film il le
fait vraiment au niveau de la politique
c'est vraiment cette idée que il faut je
dirais à son niveau c'est il faut il
faut lutter contre l'hégémonie du cinéma
hollywoodien voilà c'est on va on va
récompenser ce film pédagogique donc ça
c'est ce sont des choses qui qui
marquent et je pense que après il y a
une lignée comme ça de de grand
président du du jury qui vont être très
soucieux d'être dans je dirais dans
cette voilà dans cette non pas forcément
une actualité politique mais dans une
une ambition de politique qui est celle
de de récompenser de mettre en avant de
mettre en avant les les films qui qui
parlent de de l'état du monde et alors
je me rappelle plus quel président qui
qui couronne par exemple Michael Moore
avec Fahrenheit 9.11 mais bon c'est
évident que c'est un une palme politique
et que là le le l'autorité du président
du jury est décisive par exemple on se
souvient très bien que Sean Pen avait
prévu dans son discours d'introduction
quand il était président du jury il
avait prévenu que il primerait enfin il
ferait tout pour que la palme revienne à
un film qui parle de l'état du monde et
que en gros que ce soit politique quoi
et il a primé entre les murs de leur en
planter donc c'était qui était
effectivement qu'on peut considérer
effectivement comme un voilà
mais même la new Spike Lee président bon
d'ailleurs il annonce la Palme d'Or 2021
il fait une gaffe une gaffe lors de la
cérémonie clôture il balance la palme
avant alors que personne lui a demandé
mais quand il donne à palmatitane du
Julien Ducourneau qui est un film de
genre un film violent un film réalisé
par une femme un film sur une femme au
combien enfin forte avec vraiment toute
une problématique sur le genre la
fluidité du genre etc là aussi il est
totalement dans son dans le monde tel
qu'il est c'est à dire il va choisir
quelque chose qui est un film
qui est un film de genre mais qui a sa
manière est un film incroyablement
militant même s'il est pas politique au
sens disons de de la diplomatie et des
pays mais il est il est très fort dans
ce qu'il raconte du monde donc là aussi
c'est une on peut dire que c'est une
panne politique la plupart du temps les
pages sont d'une manière ou d'une autre
politique alors restons avec les femmes
à un moment est-ce qu'il y a eu un avant
et après-midi tout à Cannes et Dieu sait
si le phénomène Mitou
est parti du monde du cinéma et puis
parti de Cannes c'est parti de c'est
parti de Weinstein à Cannes exactement
c'est qui était pour lui une sorte de
grand bordel c'était quelque chose qui
était très très clair dans la dans la
dans la prédation de Vanessa c'est clair
oui Cannes était son Babylone et voilà
bah c'est comme ça qu'il est tombé donc
il est tombé entre
il y a comme vous dites bonnes ça sert
aussi à sentir l'atmosphère sociétale
politique du pays
me too ça dans la profession dans les
dans les films retenus par le comité de
sélection il y a un mouvement il y a eu
donc une montée des marges très
importante qui a fait quand même la
couverture du Time ça magazine du New
York Times et tout donc des femmes qui
sont montées donc dirigées par Kate
Blanchette qui était président du jury
cette année-là donc ça avait une gueule
folle Céline siama et Agnès Varda qui
était encore des nôtres et toute la
profession féminine enfin en tout cas il
y avait un nombre incroyable qui ont
monté les marches de Cannes pour dire
que elles étaient là qu'il fallait
maintenant compter sur elle que elle
elle se laisserait plus faire que ce
soit en termes salarial en termes de
présence et tout donc il y a eu des il y
a eu des moments comme ça très fort et
puis aussi parité et tentative aussi
désespéré de parité dans les films
montrer là vous nous disiez qu'il y aura
une davantage de réalisatrices cette
année
de de différents pays italiens du
Sénégal de la Tunisie des réalisatrices
françaises
beaucoup de femmes qui sont qui vont
concourir ce qui dénote en fait que il y
a plus de réalisatrices qui font des
films mais quand dans les comités de
sélection et
je crois que ça se passe comme ça j'ose
espérer que ça se passe comme ça il ne
choisissent pas le film en fonction du
genre du metteur en scène c'est à dire
que si c'est une femme très bien c'est
un homme très bien aussi ils s'en
foutent ce qu'ils veulent c'est la
qualité du film donc quand on reproche
comme on a reproché souvent
délégué général à savoir à tirer Frémaux
comme quoi il y avait tel pays n'était
pas représenté est-elle comme il avait
répondu une année il avait dit c'est le
Festival de Cannes c'est pas l'UNESCO
quoi donc et c'est pareil pour les pour
le genre quand on lui dit il y a pas
assez de femmes bah peut-être qu'il y
avait pas assez de film réalisé par des
femmes il y est pour rien lui voilà donc
là cette année ça tombe bien il y en a
plus donc tant mieux c'est en train
d'évoluer c'est pas encore ça mais c'est
en train d'évoluer
il y a deux thèmes il y a une volonté
quand même aussi de faire attention bien
sûr que on fait avec le Festival de
Cannes fait avec les films qui existent
cette année-là et qui lui sont proposés
on peut pas les inventer mais en
revanche c'est vrai qu'un un regard et
une volonté en fait de de montrer tous
les pays en fait de montrer tous les
regards que ce soit des regards
masculins féminins et de et de tous les
pays possibles dans toutes les formes de
cinéma qui peuvent exister c'est aussi
vraiment la mission du Festival de
Cannes si le Festival de Cannes est la
plus grande fenêtre sur le monde il faut
que dans cette fenêtre il y a le maximum
d'acteurs et le maximum de paysages
autrement ouvrons un tant soit peu la
fenêtre sur le monde pour finir il y a
deux thèmes majeurs qui émergent en tout
cas de ce début d'année 2023 la guerre
Ukraine toujours et encore et puis
d'Iran avec cette révolution du côté des
femmes iraniennes que nous avons vécues
depuis maintenant de longs mois et ce
qu'il faut s'attendre à ce que le
Festival de Cannes vous ne lisez pas
dans la boule de cristal mais marque le
coup une fois encore sur l'Ukraine parce
que qui était le cas déjà l'année
dernière et peut-être aujourd'hui sur
les rangs je pense que sur l'Ukraine le
festival est très attentif à ça depuis
l'année dernière sur l'Iran c'est depuis
une quinzaine d'années que le les
cinéastes iraniens parfois emprison en
Iran arrive à faire passer leur film
lors du Festival de Cannes mais bon ça
c'est quelque chose que sur lequel le
Festival de Cannes est très attentif
c'est-à-dire arriver à jouer un rôle de
vitrine pour ceux qui sont qui sont qui
ont des problèmes dans leur pays et ça
c'est un véritable rôle du Festival de
Cannes c'est à dire que c'est c'est ça
ça permet à la fois de montrer des films
de cinéaste qui sont emprisonnés et puis
ça légitime ces cinéastes aux yeux de
ces régimes et qui vont être un cas de
n'a pas réussi à faire venir et libérer
Mohamed
rassoulouf par exemple qui est toujours
bien sûr
pas naïe a été libéré c'est peut-être
en 2010 il avait été d'ailleurs membre
du jury membre du jury il y avait un
petit panneau sur son siège voilà
puisqu'il était il était astreint
résidence donc voilà et lui a pu enfin
quitter son pays il y a maintenant il y
a quelques semaines très fort ça parce
que il y a un continuum le Festival de
Cannes peut faire naître au regard du
monde des cinéastes et des cinéastes qui
sont empêchés dans leur pays comme je
vais faire panailly par exemple c'est
vrai que les synasti Rania ont vraiment
eu de la lumière à Cannes mais d'autres
aussi les Chinois vraiment ça les met en
lumière et après quand ils ont des
graves pépins chez eux le Festival de
Cannes sert un petit peu de vigie lance
des alertes vous allez au qu’est-ce que
vous faites là allez rendez-nous
rendez-le allez libérez le allez on vous
surveille on vous surveille et comme ce
sont devenus des cinéastes quand même
finalement mondialement connu on peut
plus enfin les gouvernements
autoritaires peu plus faire exactement
ce qu'ils veulent avec donc vraiment le
Festival de Cannes suit le destin de ces
cinéastes dernière question
muette odissimo l'an dernier il y avait
eu trois films Ukrainiens présentés à
Cannes dont deux en compétition
officielle est-ce que il y aura à
nouveau
un film ukrainien au moins un film
ukrainien en compétition officielle à
Cannes cette année non cette année il y
a pas de film ukrainien le problème
c'est que voilà l'année dernière la
chance la chance c'est que ils avaient
encore pu filmer donc l'année dernière
on a pu voir des films qu'ils avaient
filmé avant là ils sont en plein conflit
c'est difficile de faire du cinéma tout
de même dans ces conditions-là donc non
il n'y a pas de il n'y aura pas de film
ukrainien ça ne veut pas dire qu'il n'y
aura pas de présence ou de symboliques
on verra sur les gens qui seront
présents certains cinéastes qui voudront
qui pourront venir juste pour témoigner
mais mais pas de film mais après il y a
d'autres pays empêché ou d'autres pays
compliqués il va y avoir en compétition
un film chinois de Yang Bing qui a un
grand Cinéas chinois qui n'est pas très
copain avec son régime donc de toute
façon canela canela pour pour faire
venir des gens qui témoignent de la
complexité de leur de la géopolitique ce
sera le mot de la fin merci vraiment à
tous les trois d'avoir participé à ce
débat doc aujourd'hui on a parlé Cannes
on a parlé de thé et on a parlé de ces
moments où la politique s'invite à
Cannes et Dieu sait si on vous a bien
entendu qui lui nombreux moments où la
politique s'est invité à Cannes au-delà
de ce fameux 1968 où là le festival n'a
pas été au bout mais c'était un acte
politique là où si vous réaction ça sera
sur chaque débalox sur Twitter merci à
El massali qui comme à la coutumée m'a
aidé à préparer cette émission moi je
vous retrouve pour un prochain débat doc
avec bien sûr son documentaire et son
débat à bientôt
[Musique]